[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro d' envies de lecture autour de
moi trois invités armée de rigaud
bonjour un show vous êtes responsable
des manifestations culturelles et
scientifiques de la bibliothèque
universitaire de saint quentin en
yvelines et vous êtes venu me parler
d'un catalogue d'exposition leur hangar
un bon niveau dans l'habitude de
l'émission vous êtes venu nous présenter
deux ouvrages c'est ça sur 50 en
mathématiques quand on nous avait
jacques chancel et les graffitis parfait
et francisco star bonjour vous êtes
directeur programmateur de la merise et
vous êtes venu nous parler d'un coup de
coeur ce matin merci à vous dora on va
attaquer avec vous armelle bonjour
champions on se connaît bien à travers
le festival saint quentin on a travaillé
ensemble sur cette édition qui vient de
s'achever et aujourd'hui vous venez nous
parler d'une d'un catalogue d'exposition
qui re de coups de coeur tu es beaucoup
de gars oui icône de mai 68 c'est une
exposition qui a été réalisée par la
bibliothèque nationale qui a eu lieu sur
le site françois-mitterrand de d'avril
jusqu'en 26 août 2018 alors ce qui m'a
plu dans
dans ce catalogue un d'exposition c'est
que loin de retracer les événements de
mai 68 qui parle plutôt d'une
construction culturelle et notamment sur
la mémoire visuelle collective des
événements de mai 68 selon même qu'elle
procédait certaines photographies comme
la couverture du catalogue sont passés
du statut d'icône et qui aujourd'hui
continue d'illustrer les événements donc
ce catalogue est riche puisque la
bibliothèque nationale des pins possède
un fonds de plus de 20 me de documents
concernant les événements de mai 68
parce que j'ai aimé dans ce catalogue
c'est ces deux en fait ces deux figure
d'icône notamment que l'image de cohn
bendit qui fait face aux crs que tout le
monde connaît bien qui oppose
aujourd'hui
voilà qui illustre le duel entre les crs
et la jeunesse de l'époque un peu le
temps récolté complètement d'actualité
donc 7,7 photographique a été prise
donc dans mes 68 donc montre bien que
aujourd'hui même si elle a pas été
publiés dans les années 68 elle a été
largement diffusée dans les années
soixante dix voire même plus dans les
années soixante dix huit donc elle vient
d'un
d'un photographe gilles caron qui était
à l'époque photographe pour une jeune
agence prometteuse parce que c' est l'
agence gamma qui est né en 1967 et à
force d'être utilisé un depuis tous ces
anniversaires décennies de mai 68
ok on se rend compte et le catalogue ce
que j'ai trouvé intéressant sur la
couverture on le voit bien plus de plus
en plus cadré pour finir exclusivement
sur la figure david cohn bendit alors il
ya deuxième photo qui a marqué les
photos sont biffés par les photographes
tu as fait un don de 2 ans voit
également comme baby comme on le voit
très alors en fait que c'est
pratiquement la même et en photos
couleurs hein c'est ce qui montre aussi
également dans ce catalogue d'exposition
pourquoi les archives de 2,68 ont plutôt
été en noir et blanc he et aussi de
couleur rouge
on s'est habitué dans notre mémoire
collective alors que la couleur était
déjà utilisé alors certes mais bon voilà
de l'époque un donc je pense à paris
match le le poids des mots le choc des
photos je pense aussi à l'express
servan-schreiber et puis également le
nouvel observateur qui sont l'âge d'or
en fait un du photojournalisme donc la
deuxième photographique moi j'ai
beaucoup normalement qui se trouve sur
la couverture du catalogue
donc moi je connaissais pas l'histoire
de cette photographie oui qu'est la
marianne lehmann est quelqu'un qui n'est
pas français
leur vie n'est pas alors et les
françaises mais surtout elle vient de
new york elle a été longtemps à vivre à
new york elle était mannequin elle a
milité contre la guerre au vietnam
et donc quand elle arrive à paris en
fait on se rend compte que cette
photographie elle n'est pas née du
hasard elle ya été construite en fait
parce que bon elle bat le pavé comme
beaucoup de d'étudiante et cette époque
puisque c'est la manifestation unitaire
qui a rassemblé des milliers de
personnes
elle a mal aux pieds elle s'est même sur
l'épaule de me voilà qui est quand même
jean pierre louvel qui est plasticien de
l'époque yann ses camarades qui lui
donne un drapeau c'est le drapeau du du
front de libération sud vietnam
elle se elle prend la pose parce qu'elle
s'est rendue compte qu'elle les
photographier et donc je pense que par
son métier de mannequin il le dit plus
tard parce qu'elle a été interviewé bien
des fois concernant cette photo est allé
photographier au tout près des grilles
du jardin du luxembourg
d'autres femmes 1 2 les packs ont brandi
le drapeau 1 soit le drapeau noir des
anarchistes ou bien le drapeau bleu
blanc rouge
lors de la manifestation de soutien du
général de gaulle et pourtant c'est ses
photographies ne sont pas tombées non
pas verser dans le statut d'icône par
dante mais je vous entends pas ce qu'on
pourrait parler parler parler des heures
de mai 68 est particulièrement
aujourd'hui on rappelle juste que la
commissaire s'était audrey leblanc
docteur en histoire et civilisation
l'université de lille iii et que de
toute l'exposition est partie de ceux de
sa thèse de doctorat sur l'image de
mai-68 du journalisme à l'histoire
oui elle a été aidé également par des
conservateurs la bible versavel qui la
conservatrice département des estampes
et c'est parfait merci à vous interview
on va passer avoue francis costard et
vous venez nous parler d'un livre très
connu déjà petit pays de galles faille
qu'est ce qui vous a déjà moi je voulais
emmener à des artistes vont tous pour
s'acheter un spectacle dont il est à la
fois écrivain et surtout c'est un
slameur
rappeur et puis il a écrit un livre qui
raconte son histoire enfants voilà donc
l'immigration depuis l'histoire commence
au burundi où il a grandi voilà donc
orgueil c'est un pseudonyme s'appelle
gabriel et ce qui est intéressant c'est
ben on voit comment à l'enfant bas avec
un parent avec un père qui est
entrepreneur français et vit dans un
quartier résidentiel du burundi sa mère
et et rwandaise et puis bah tout se
passe bien lui fait les 400 coups avec
ses copains tous les puits là d'un seul
coup qui est sous ce qui se passe bien
sûr c'est une guerre civile et il se
retrouve le divorce de ses parents et
puis se retrouve entraîné dans cette
liste de machines non contre le pas
quand on a dix ans avec ba des avis
divergents re son père voilà avec
nationale toute son éducation française
et puis sa mère avec ses racines et on
se retrouve donc lui confronté justement
parce qu'on peut retrouver l'enfant le
son issu de la médiane du tissage de
général enfin de complètement de
civilisations différentes
et puis il est au coeur du conflit le
voit et puis il le vit on va dire commun
avec un maison
le regard d'un enfant de 10 ans et puis
avec sa petite soeur c'est pas évident
voilà et qu'il va fuir le combat viril
va être à partir en france voilà il va
être accueilli dans sa famille voilà
d'afrique de son père et puis bah voilà
et c'est toute son histoire et le livre
retrace tout ce parcours jusqu'à jusqu'à
la seine ou pas sinon jusqu'à la seine
jusqu'à jusqu'à son départ
vers la france et puis après son retour
au pays voilà la retour au pays et j'ai
pas de spolier
ces normes le lire c'est un prix
concours des lycéens de l'es16 oui 2016
et gros succès sur le sur scène et gros
succès littéraire aussi parce que c'est
jean gérard fc de pouvoir accueillir un
jour et thalys ont parlé tous les deux
de ce livre et puis en même temps de
l'accueillir sur scène pour un concert
plaisir et c'est une voie là c'est une
façon différente de rencontrer un
artiste
voilà par l'écriture déjà c'est un
slameur c'est un rappeur donc il sait
écrire mais là il raconte son histoire
et c'est vraiment très touchant et ça me
donne pas que ce soit le prix goncourt
des lycéens passe quelque chose qui se
lit très rapidement très facilement qui
a porté tous puissent et voilà c'est moi
je pense que les siens se retrouver
aussi dans mes dans l'écriture et puis
et puis dans l'histoire de gaël quoi et
c'est vraiment très bien mais je pense
que cela donnera envie aux
téléspectateurs
j'espère découvert celui ci n'ont pas
déjà découvrir leurs hangars un grand
jour tu règle avec deux énormes livre
oui de vos livres un peu en raisonnant
sur le hip hop donc le graffiti 50 ans
d'interaction urbaine donc c'est un peu
comme si michel foucault faisait une
étude du graffiti donc pour une fois il
n'ya pas uniquement que des belles
photos puisqu'il ya des superbes photos
on peut voir ici par exemple mais il ya
toute une étude sociologique fait par
deux sociologues et donc le texte vient
vraiment en résonance de des graffitis
sur l'explication comment ça s'est créé
comment ça se forme
comment ça se développe l'onag le tag
sac et son nom
alors oui au départ donc ça passe ça
partait sur du vandalisme urbain et
maintenant c'est rentrer dans les
institutions comme ans a réussi à passer
ses frontières là c'est toujours resté
hors les musées ça restera hors les
musées mais ça rentre quand même qu'un
jeu de plus en plus dans les galeries
donc on essaye un peu de d'enfermer tout
ça donc c'est l'eau qui ce qu'un artiste
graffeur français mais internationale
kiki graff un peu partout et voilà donc
c'est un superbe roman
enfin c'est un superbe look un pardon
mes os et c'est aussi une étude
sociologique donc avec une vraie
profondeur en sursis c'est pas que de la
photo c'est la foudre a cette fois ci
n'est qu'elle appelait il ya vraiment
une vraie analyse si on devra étude
sociologique du mouvement hip hop grosse
moitié un monde vraiment très codifié
avec des fils de hiérarchie
aristocratique j'avais oui c'est ça il
ya des stratifiés mieux c'est marie jo
ann farrell joe and haas qui a le one
deux premiers essais c'est une espèce de
hiérarchie très aristocratique seulement
dans le tas il ya différentes sont pas
des strates comme ça à hiérarchiser on
ne traite pas être le tag de quelqu'un
c'est une histoire de territoire
enfin ça parle de tout ça il ya une
vraie étude sociologique qui est
vraiment très profonde qui est superbe
et très bien et un deuxième ouvrage est
un deuxième ouvrage qui est bien
différent donc les radioscopies sur
jacques chancel son émission qui a duré
20 ans qui était quotidienne donc il
reste encore le maître à penser de pas
mal de monde donc c'est busnel qui fait
la préface ma pour voilà situer le
contexte est donc ce sont des interviews
qu'il a mené tout au long des émissions
qu on retrace à l'écrit
donc on passe d'adjani gainsbourg bardot
voilà et tout ce qui s'est dit lors de
ces émissions est en train une galerie
de portraits des années 70
principalement c'est surtout autour des
années 70 tous les tous débuts des
années 80 et voilà on se replonge dans
le monde artistique culturel de la
france de l'époque et on revit tout ça
et on voit là et c'est aussi un très bon
moment qu'on passe et finalement on se
rend compte aussi que jacques chancel a
apporté beaucoup de choses puisque voilà
tout le monde s'en inspire encore
aujourd'hui est vrai nom c'est
intéressant de relire tout ça très bien
il nous reste une minute pour ce que
vous avez des agendas que je voulais
mettre en avant pour les pour cette fin
d'année
moi j'ai très envie d'aller à la merise
prochainement la mairie bien tour soit
un slameur rappeur donc hippocampe fou
voilà sauvé l'odyssée d'ipo voilà c'est
un voyage en 80 rêve voilà donc bah
c'est pas bon se meurt
qui va faire un spectacle jeune public
et donc il va décliner ce spectacle avec
du mapping avec 2
la vidéoprojection projections etc et
appui après ben
pourquoi venir écouter bas bientôt on
reçoit
tiken jah fakoly le 23 mars voilà et
puis également fait chatterton à 8h29
la scam d'après partout voilà et puis
moi j'ai un petit culture sur ma
programmation
voilà on reçoit luc langevin s'éteint
c'est un magicien ces révisionnistes
voilà c'est un artiste québécois est sa
première en france ce sera chez nous
sommes bien préparés toute sa tournée
avant de partir partout en france ont
très bien merci beaucoup d'être venu
dans cette nouvelle édition des envies
de lecture et puis on se retrouve très
bientôt pour un nouveau mieux le numéro
et merci encore à vous d'être d'être
venu me rejoindre sur ce plateau ce
matin à très bientôt
[Musique]